[Musique]
nous sommes donc andy âge
nous sommes dans une époque formidable
où il ya plein d'innovations
spectaculaire il ya des grandes avancées
notamment dans la santé des progrès
sociaux
on arrive même à réduire l'extrême
pauvreté et de l'autre côté les
équilibres se creuse quelques chiffres
pour vous partager un peu de réflexion
chaque année un tiers de la nourriture
produite est jetée alors qu'une personne
sur neuf continue à souffrir de
malnutrition
huit personnes détiennent la même
richesse que 50% de la population
mondiale
huit personnes si on rajoute à ça des
indicateurs démographiques la population
mondiale grandit chaque année de
l'équivalent d'un pays comme la france
80 millions d'habitants en plus sur
notre planète chaque année et puis
également quelques indicateurs sur la
raréfaction des ressources nous mettons
sept mois à consommer le volume de
ressources que la terre mais un an à
régénérer nous sommes dans l'extra
consommation de nos ressources
voilà vous l'avez compris on est de plus
en plus nombreux on a des ressources qui
ne sont pas infinies qu'en plus on
gaspille et les écarts entre les
richesses se creusa le tableau est assez
simple il faut changer
yes we can le changement c'est
maintenant en marche
tout le monde est d'accord c'est super
et on commence même à prendre conscience
que ce changement va devoir passer par
nous pour cent pourtant ça ne date pas
d'hier
il y avait un monsieur formidable jazzy
et ce sera ma seule phrase en anglais
big challenge i want to see in the world
alors qu'est ce qui se passe pour qu'on
change pas on est tous d'accord
pourquoi on change pas plus vite c'est
quoi nos freins en fait
moi je pense que changer c'est super dur
c'est probablement la chose la plus dure
qu'on est à faire et puis en plus on n'a
pas de mode d'emploi
on a la pression il faut changer mais on
sait pas où aller comment démarrer du
coup ce soir j'ai voulu parler de ces
sujets là avec une un regard différent
déjà changer de vocabulaire ne pas ne
pas vous parler de changement mais
plutôt parler de reconnexion avec
nous-mêmes ne pas parler de ce super
woman mais vous parlez plutôt
d'introspection j'ai aussi voulu vous
partager la recette ma recette
personnelle avec mes deux ingrédients
secrets qui m'ont permis de m'adapter
pour ne pas dire changer mes deux
ingrédients secrets liberté et
responsabilité ils sont pas très secret
mais c'est pas grave
souvent on pense que ces deux forces
s'opposent et moi au contraire je pense
que quand on les cantons les mais l'une
avec l'autre canton les z à cohabiter
ensemble elles forment une puissance
extrêmement importante qui est le
terreau de notre mise en mouvement de
notre action la liberté nous père nous
permet de bouger de sortir du cadre et
la responsabilité nous permet d'avancer
dans une direction de construire
en tout cas moi ce sont les deux forces
qui m'ont aidé à grandir qui m'ont
nourri et qui m'ont même à mon insu
farhi vais là où j'en suis je dis à mon
insu parce que c'est en préparant ce ted
que je me suis rendu compte du lien
entre cette image le parcours que j'ai
fait est là où je suis aujourd'hui je
suis né dans un petit village gaulois en
bretagne donc où contrairement aux idées
reçues le passe temps favori n'est pas
de chasser le sanglier mais de partir en
mer ce bateau et beaucoup d'autres avant
et quelques autres après c'est un peu ma
deuxième maison
ce que j'aime quand je suis comme ça sur
ce bateau c'est que je me sens
extrêmement libre qui livre de voguer au
gré du vent libre de découvrir des
endroits inconnus libre d'observer le
paysage libre du temps long que nous
offre le bateau est libre aussi de
lâcher prise parce que de toute façon en
bateau s'est jamais vraiment vous qui
décidez mais sur cette image je suis un
peu concentré quand même car il ya des
grosses vagues derrière moi je suis
responsable je suis responsable parce
que je dois faire face aux éléments je
dois passer au delà de la tempête
je dois décider d'une route on doit
décider d'une route puisque je n'étais
pas tout seul je vous rassure c'est mon
aventuriers qui était avant moi j'ai pas
fait d' aventure extraordinaire
je lui laissais en fait raconté en vrai
j'ai fait des trucs incroyables mais bon
on ne pouvait pas dire la même chose
donc je vois là on est responsable on
est responsable de nos gestes de nos
décisions
et puis on est aussi responsable de la
vie à bord parce que quand on traverse
l'atlantique
il n'y a pas d'arrêt à la buvette il
faut gérer la nourriture l'eau la bonne
entente avant du bateau donc voilà c'est
une expérience que je voulais vous
partagez de ce que m'a appris la vie en
mer et finalement c'est quelque chose
que j'ai perpétuer tout au long de ma
vie j'ai toujours privilégié ce rapport
entre la liberté et la responsabilité la
liberté parce que j'avais pas envie de
suivre le cursus des grandes écoles j'ai
préféré apprendre sur le terrain parce
que quand par emma semble m'a semblé
oppressant j'étais m'installer dans un
petit village au coeur de la provence au
plus près de la nature
la liberté aussi parce que j'ai préféré
embarqués dans des entreprises à taille
humaine plutôt que de sillonner les
couloirs des grandes entreprises
mais j'ai toujours été responsable j'ai
toujours été engagée dans mon autonomie
mon indépendance
chaque projet que j'ai mené j'ai mené
avec ambition j'avais envie que ça me
fasse grandir et avancer
j'ai souvent dit grandir sans mal j'ai
beaucoup grandi dans ma vie pour ça tu
changes juste rire en tout cas quand
j'arrive au bout du chemin
je me rends compte que j'ai juste mener
un parcours qui me ressemble à mon
rythme où j'ai su privilégier ma vie de
famille la qualité de vie et mon
épanouissement professionnel et je vais
vous faire une petite confidence c'est
pas trés tedx mais j'ai jamais chercher
un sens à ma vie parce que ma vie est
pleine de sens au quotidien de mon sens
et dans mon parcours évidemment j'ai
confronté ma vision avec d'autres donc
j'ai des gens qui ont associé la liberté
avec le pouvoir et l'enrichissement
mais quelque part aussi au fond d'eux
ils ne voient plus les chaînes et les
contraintes qu'ils ont accepté en
contrepartie ou al'inverse j'ai aussi
rencontré des gens qui voulaient sortir
du système qui rejette le système
souvent je les ai trouvés un peu
prisonnier d'une vision dogmatique
qu'ils avaient même parfois en colère de
ce système tel qu'il rejetait pourtant
n'est donc pas libre qui le pensent et
la liberté en réalité c'est bien fragile
à manier
parce que la liberté il faut la chercher
à l'intérieur de nous n'est pas
l'extérieur
en rejoignant ce parc news j'ai la
grande chance de mettre au quotidien en
de mettre en avant des gens très simples
on top des gens très libre et très
responsable qui met au qui trouve pardon
des solutions aux grands enjeux du monde
ce sont des gens ordinaires qui ont mis
toute leur expérience leur énergie pour
améliorer le monde qui les entoure ce
sont des gens qui oeuvrent pour qu'ils
aient une meilleure diversité dans nos
sociétés qui réduisent la consommation
de ressources qui préserve notre
biodiversité
qui favorise l'accès à la santé à
l'éducation à l'énergie qui booste
l'économie circulaire dont on a tant
besoin
ce sont des gens qui viennent de pays
développés ou en voie de développement
qui ont un point commun ils n'ont pas
attendu
ils n'ont pas critiqué ils n'ont pas
renoncé ils ont pris la liberté d'agir à
leur échelle et ils se sont
responsabilisés pour que leurs actions
et des résultats et de l'impact
il croyait moi ils ont réussi ces
personnes là ils sont admirables pour
deux raisons la première c'est qu'elle
nous montre déjà que des solutions très
simples peuvent être apportées aux
grands problèmes et la seconde qui est
très puissante pour nous c'est que l
écrivent une nouvelle histoire un
nouveau récit d'un monde qui j'espère
nous l'espérons donnera envie à tout le
monde d'agir parce que si on y regarde
d'un peu plus près pourquoi on arrive
est ce que le récit actuelle vous donne
envie d'agir moi j'ai souvent
l'impression qu'ils nous décourage qui
nous emprisonnent ce récit actuelle
c'est quoi
ce sont malheureusement les médias
malgré le développement salvateur du
journalisme de solutions qui continuent
à mettre à la une de leurs journaux les
catastrophes les problèmes ce soit aussi
les paroles en colère des militants qui
nous responsabilise sur nos modes de vie
et puis ce sont les propos rassurants
des grands patrons qui nous expliquent
qu'ils ont tout contre tout compris mais
qui continue à diriger leur entreprise
par le profit pour terme et les
dividendes
il ya un gros brouhaha du coup sûr ce
récit et puis en plus à l'intérieur de
ce récit à des questions essentielles
qui sont clivante
vous êtes pour ou contre le nucléaire la
voiture électrique c'est une innovation
de dengue ou c'est la prochaine crise
écologique est ce que le bio va
permettre à tous d'avoir une
alimentation durable
c'est pas simple de trouver la voie le
chemin pour avancer parce que le récit
n'est pas simple alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait
on attend
on attend que les gouvernements fassent
on attend que les scientifiques ou les
chercheurs trouvent des solutions
on attend que les empires s'écroule où
on attend que d'autres empires nes et
c'est pour ça que c'est si important
pour nous de mettre en avant ses acteurs
de changement parce qu'ils nous
transmettent leur liberté d'agir à notre
échelle il nous transmettre la liberté
de ne pas avoir peur des petits pas et
il nous responsabilise parce qu'ils
créent ces nouveaux modèles économiques
qui sont viables et qui sont possibles
en réalité ce sont eux que nous devrions
suivre ce sont eux qu'on devrait starisé
à l'exact opposé des grands géants qui
nous assène régulièrement la
superpuissance la réussite financière
imaginez par exemple qu'est la une des
journaux on parle du docteur gamal al
bin saïd
c'est un jeune médecin indonésien qui à
l'âge de 25 ans en avait marre de voir
des enfants ou mourir de diarrhée dans
ses bras parce qu'ils n'avaient pas eu
accès aux soins suffisamment tôt il a
une idée assez simple et assez puissante
il a créé de garbage clinical insurance
système où les patients payent leurs
consultations en sacs de déchets il
résout plusieurs problèmes
déjà il permet d'accéder à la santé il
permet de donner une valeur à du déchet
puisque lui revalorise le déchet
derrière en le mettant dans les centres
de tri et donc il permet de réduire les
déchets de réduire la pollution par les
déchets diamal ne s'arrête pas là il
soigne des milliers de personnes autour
de lui et il lance maintenant des
programmes de santé de e-santé
en connectant des praticiens de la santé
avec des villages qui sont des déserts
médicaux
c'était simple il fallait y penser il
l'a fait parlons maintenant de francs
kaufman franco planète un médecin
allemand gynécologue allemand qui a
découvert que les femmes non voyantes
pouvait détecter des tumeurs des cancers
du sein dans la palpation deux fois
plutôt qu'un généraliste normal ils
forment les femmes non voyantes il leur
donne un emploi ils sauvent des vies et
il réduit le coût de la santé c'est pas
magnifique discovery news le nom de son
entreprise est née en allemagne elle a
été répliquée en inde en colombie en
autriche et bientôt en france une femme
une sandra elle est anglaise elle a
cette idée géniale de placer dans les
sous sols des immeubles ses tanks
ces réservoirs ces containers les
containers récupère toutes les tous les
déchets organiques de l'immeuble et les
transforment par méthanisation en eau et
en électricité
c'est à benji c'est une révolution
industrielle en soi ça permet de
d'éviter le déplacement de déchets ces
containers peuvent générer 1000 tonnes
pardon de déchets par an
ça permet d éviter de transport de
déchets ça permet d'autonomiser en
énergie ces immeubles et ça permet aussi
d'apporter de l'énergie dans des lieux
qui ne sont pas connectés qui sont pas
vérifiées cendras sasso à développer son
entreprise dans 13 pays d'entrepreneurs
un peu plus près de chez nous peut-être
certains le connaissent
emery jacquillat emery a racheté la
camif je sais pas si vous connaissez la
camif entreprise de vente de mobilier
par correspondance la camif avait un peu
raté le virage du digital emmy r est
rachetée cette entreprise un euro
symbolique sur au tribunal de commerce
de niort
il retrouve une entreprise exemple pu
tellement d'énergie positive et il
décide de redresser cette entreprise en
mettant au coeur de l'entreprise des
valeurs qui lui sont chères
ils s'engagent à ne pas créer à ne pas
réduire les emplois ne pas licencier
garder des emplois sur le territoire
ils s'engagent à ne vendre que des
produits made in france
il va faire la tournée des fabricants de
mobilier il leur apprend à faire des
meubles à base d'économie circulaire
donc en recyclant des déchets et il en
plus fait de la pédagogie à ses
consommateurs puisqu'il propose à ses
consommateurs d'acheter des biens les
plus près de chez eux au bon prix au
juste prix
la cami fête ses 10 ans cette année
ils font 40 millions de rothschild
affaire qui luttent contre des géants de
la vente par internet
et il a quatre cent mille clients dans
deux tiers de nouveaux clients des gens
des clients des consommateurs qui ont
été sensibles à la proche débris de
transformer le consommateur en
consom'acteurs et ça c'est hyper
important parce que justement il a
réussi à transformer des actes de
consommation
donc imaginez si toutes ces personnes
étaient dans le quotidien de vos
journaux autour de vous ils pourraient
nous nourrir avec leurs modèles
il pourrait nous donner envie d'agir
parce qu'ils nous apportent une
créativité une ingéniosité ils ont
transformé des problèmes en solutions et
finalement ils nous permettent à tous de
trouver des nouveaux modèles dans nos
façons d'être est ce que ça vous donne
plus envie d'agir que d'entendre que la
terre va mal
moi oui et je vous rassure pour agir
vous n'avez pas besoin de changer de vie
vous avez pas besoin de trouver l'idée
du siècle
vous pouvez tous agir à votre échelle si
vous êtes étudiant à les challenge et
les entreprises avec lesquelles vous
passer des entretiens et demandez à vos
entreprises quels qu'ils font qu'est ce
qu'ils font pour la planète et pour
l'homme
vous verrez au bout de trois entretiens
les gens en face de vous vous changez
ils vont avoir trouvé des choses à dire
en tout cas si vous êtes salarié ne
claquez pas la porte de la de votre
entreprise vous la connaissez mieux que
personne
au contraire essayer de voir autour de
vous comment vous pouvez transformer
votre job au quotidien le rendre plus
inclusif plus respectueux de
l'environnement
allez embarquer les gens autour de vous
allez parler à vos managers avons rh
proposer des idées si vous êtes patron
investisseurs alors là c'est tranquille
vous faites un séminaire ouvert et vous
revoyez tout simplement le modèle
économique de votre entreprise
en intégrant à l'intérieur l'impact
social et environnemental que vous allez
mettre pas à côté un pas dans une
fondation à l'intérieur du business
si vous êtes aucun de ces trois cas là
vous êtes des consommateurs vous avez un
pouvoir le pouvoir de votre achat de
votre acte d'achat
vous pouvez décider de consommer des
fruits et des légumes de saison
vous pouvez décider d'agir d'acheter
quand vous en avez besoin et pas quand
le marketing vous insuffle et vous dit
d'aller acheter parce que c'est le black
friday
vous pouvez aussi agir en tant que
citoyen un peu comme on l'a fait
aujourd'hui
en décidant de diffuser ces histoires
libre et ses histoires responsable en
décidant que toutes ces histoires c'est
votre quotidien vous avez envie de lire
ça vous avez envie de partager ça à vos
réseaux vous êtes un média vous même ne
l'oublié pas donc fait grandir ses
histoires et diffuser les
voilà je crois que vous a à peu près
tout dit je vous semble peut être prêt à
partir en bateau mais à vendre hisser la
grand-voile
on va faire un dernier petit tour de
météo une petite réflexion que je vous
laisse pour vous quand vous aurez le
temps mais posez vous cette question
suis-je libre suis libre de consommer à
la hauteur de mes besoins et de mes
envies raisonnable suis-je libre de
réussir sans desservir mon bonheur et
mon équilibre
suis-je responsable
est ce que je me contribue réellement
aux causes qui m'intéressent qui me
tiennent à coeur
suis-je responsable car mon combat ne
dépend que de moi je m'engage moi et mes
convictions je vous souhaite un très bon
vent à tous merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]